hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about how to use mannitol salt
agar so mannitol salt agar
is a kind of bacterial growth media that
has a few cool characteristics the first
is that it is a selective medium
selective means that it allows the
growth of some organisms while
inhibiting the growth of others so there
are other types of media that are non
selective things like algae auger or
nutrient agar that if you expose them to
environmental bacteria lots and lots of
different things will grow on that kind
of agar but mannitol salt agar is
selective it allows some organisms to
grow and not others so specifically in
the case of mannitol salt agar it allows
the growth of Staphylococcus species so
species that are in the Jena
Staphylococcus would include things like
Staphylococcus aureus or Staphylococcus
epidermidis if you hear someone talking
about having a staph infection it's an
infection by some species within this
genus mannitol salt agar also allows
bacteria that are in the micro [ __ ]
let's see micro copy see a little bit of
different difficult one to spell micro
pog ACA to grow so for example things
like Micrococcus luteus can grow on
mannitol salt agar
and the reason that it allows these to
grow is because they can survive the
relatively high salt concentration of
this auger so this auger is about eight
to ten percent salt and so that tends to
inhibit other bacteria so for example if
you were looking under a microscope
after having done
Stane you would know that Staphylococcus
and Micrococcus are both gram positive
cocci mean that their spheres and shape
but mannitol salt agar can let you know
that you're working with either
Staphylococcus or Micrococcus
and definitely not streptococcus which
is another gram positive caucus no round
shaped bacterium because it can't live
in that high salt concentration so the
high salt concentration inhibits not
only the growth of streptococcus but
also the growth of virtually all
gram-negative bacteria mannitol salt
agar has another interesting
characteristic in addition to being
selective it is considered a deferential
nyanma
so differential media means that it
contains chemicals that visually
distinguish species based on their
biochemical characteristics so you can
see with your eyes that some colonies
are a different species than another
based on their biochemical
characteristics in the case of mannitol
salt agar specifically the way that it
is differential is it contains mannitol
mannitol is a sugar alcohol basically a
kind of carbohydrate and it contains the
pH indicator of phenol red this is what
gives the the mantle salt augur its
characteristic kind of bright pink color
and so because it has mannitol and his
peach indicator phenol red the pH
indicator will have a color change when
it detects acid so when acid is produced
from bacteria that can ferment the
mannitol so remember mantle is a
carbohydrate if the bacteria can ferment
it it's going to result in an acid
byproduct and that is going to that that
acid is going to drop the pH which is
going to change the color of the ph
indicator creating a yellow zone not
sure why around has two hours there
right have a have a yellow zone around
the colonies that are composed of a
bacterial species that confirm at the
mannitol so again mannitol salt agar is
selective it allows only Staphylococcus
and micro Cox e8 bacteria to be able to
grow and it's differential if you see a
yellow zone it means that that bacteria
can permit mannitol so let's take a look
at how this works in practice here I've
drawn an agar plate with four quadrants
and we're going to see what four
different kinds of bacteria would look
like on a mannitol salt agar blank so
the first one will consider is
streptococcus pyogenes streptococcus
pyogenes is a member of the
streptococcus genus and that is one of
the types of bacteria that is inhibited
by this type of honor that means that
even if streptococcus pyogenes if a
culture was added to this quadrant and
the plate was incubated nothing is going
to grow on the other hand Staphylococcus
epidermidis Micrococcus luteus and
Staphylococcus aureus are all going to
be able to grow on mannitol salt agar
because they are members of either the
Staphylococcus genus or the micro proxy
a family and so Staphylococcus
epidermidis
would be able to grow so would
Micrococcus luteus and so would
Staphylococcus aureus so that's the
selected portion these three can can
grow this one is inhibited now let's
talk about the differential portion
remember that if any of these three
types of bacteria can ferment the
mannitol that's going to cause the color
change with the pH indicator when the
acid is produced resulting in a yellow
zone and it turns out that
Staphylococcus epidermidis and
Micrococcus luteus do not permit
mannitol there are other sources of
nutrition
the manifold algorithm they can use and
so they'll grow but they will not change
the color of the mannitol cell water on
the other hand Staphylococcus aureus is
going to be able to grow and ferment the
mannitol resulting in a yellow zone and
unfortunately I don't have a yellow dry
erase markers but there would be sort of
a yellow zone basically the portion of
the plate where Staphylococcus aureus
was present would be a really
distinctive yellow color I encourage you
to google mannitol salt agar plate and
do a google image search and you can see
some really interesting images that show
that distinctive yellow zone now if
you're interested in learning more about
gram positive versus gram-negative
bacteria I used those terminology when
talking about the gram positive bacteria
that can grow here and then the ones
that are inhibited like gram positive
streptococcus and all gram negative
bacteria if you want to know more about
what those words mean grandpas
dendrogram negative you can check out my
video on grande positive versus gram
negative bacteria but this will be it
for today so thank you for watching
biology professor